hallo YouTube chest lowers in my friends
this is grunge in here welcome to the
seventh episode of my chest sariputta
against evil in this episode we are
going to see Scotch came from the back
perspective now as per our do I put the
water the scotch game arises after efore
Knight to c6 d 4e 5 Knight to f3 pawn
captures and in the fifth and the sixth
episode of my Chester prota I have
covered some gambit ideas by white so if
you haven't check it out you can
certainly have a look at them but in
this game we are going to concentrate on
the proper squads game which arises
after the water Knight captures d4 now
the same position can also be reached by
a different Mordor so for example if you
are a Foley 5 player then after Knight
to f3 Knight to c6 d4 pawn captures and
Knight captures we reach to the same
position now here black has plenty of
choices but the choice I have made is
very dynamic and the most important part
is it limits the white option here I'm
proposing that black should continue
with the move Knight to f6 so straight
away this night is pressurizing the e4
square and that's why white options are
very much limited now mainly there are
two moves try by the white one is Knight
captures c6 and then pushing this point
forward and the second one is defending
this efore pawn with the move Knight to
c3 in this video we are going to see
Knight captured c6 in my next episode I
am going to concentrate on the move
Knight to c3 after Knight captures black
should obviously capture with the be
pawn and now if light to c3 at this
point then it will transpose to the line
which we are going to see in the next
episode so there are two independent
move tried by the white over here
now the ephah is the main move over here
but instead of ePHI there is a one
fashionable line right now in the scotch
game that is Bishop to d3 the idea is
when black plays the obvious mood defy
white is going to push with the movie
file now instead of ePHI if again white
capture the pawn then it will transpose
to the line which we are going to see in
the next episode so let's see what will
happen after white plays the obvious
movie file well here black has to play
very accurately because if you don't
know the theory over here then you can
easily get into the trouble especially
in the opening and you have to remember
this more black has to play Knight to g4
attacking defy the theory goes with the
castle on the Kings side now you play
this important move Bishop to c5
so pinning the F pawn and stopping Group
two even ideas white continue here with
the move Queen to e2 defending the ePHI
we didn't you one more time with the
move Queen to e7 and now the only way to
defend that pawn is Bishop to b4 and at
first sight it looks like white is doing
very good
but after black's next reply that is G
Phi I think white is in a huge trouble
the problem over here is Bishop to g3 is
not at all advisable the simple reason
is then black comments his King side
attack instantly with the MU H Phi and
you can already see that 4 is coming and
if I try to kick this night with the mu
H 3 then the situation can get worst
after the move h4
so after few exchange it is only black
who is in the driving seat so it is
clear that Bishop to d3 is not possible
the best move suggested by engine is
Bishop to d2 but after that I can simply
capture this pawn and remain a solid
pawn advantage no matter however white
attacks for example rook to e1 Bishop to
d6 Bishop to c3 f6 Knight to d2 and now
simply castle on the Kings side ok black
has an open King but after all he is a
simple pawn up and there is no immediate
threat
black king so this is an advantageous
position for the black okay let's see
the main line which start with the movie
fight
well after that black has to obviously
continue here with the moon Queen to e7
painting that pawn and the only good
reply for the right over here is Quint
we to kinda note if I'd continue here
with the MU f4 then the simplest plan I
have highlighted by the arrows over here
that is you play d6 Knight to d7 and if
require you can play epics and severely
pressurizing the poor one and in some
lines even black and win that one so the
only critical reply over here is Queen
to e2 afterwards next should continue
with the move Knight to d5 and this is
pretty much the starting position of the
main line of the squash now the main
moves our here our c4 and night to d2
but apart from that if you open and
place other moves then let me highlight
the plan of the campaign by the black it
is very simple and easy to remember plan
for the black so what you have to do is
to play the mood g6 followed by the move
Bishop to g7 then castle on the King
side and then start attacking the e5
weaknesses which in many cases turns out
pick a spot in the white camp
so for example if you open and continue
here with the move such as b3 or g3 then
you can certainly go ahead and fall off
with this plum and in fact you are going
to see this plant in the action with the
male line waters so let's see them so
fast and the obvious main line I want to
consider is c4 which is the highest
played move by the white well here black
can play the moonlight to b6 but I think
it's bit passive so the move which I'm
going to recommend is Bishop to a6
so black is trying to complete his
development with based on some pin
tactics now as for the theory there are
four good moves which I have highlighted
by the arrows so let's see each by time
the first and obvious move you should
know is Queen to e4 is
good move the simple reason is let's say
if black horns black and do some
repetitions but interrupts that I'm
recommending that you should continue
here with the move Knight to b4 and it's
a very tricky move to meet for example
the most obvious response such as III
turns out as a blunder because of the
wonderful reply by a black that is D Phi
so Queen cannot protect c2 anymore so
for example after pawn captures pawn
captures the support on the c2 has gone
and if white things have been a piece
after Queen captures then if you closely
look at it after Queen captures Aoife it
is white who has lost the Queen well you
might say well III is not force how
about a white plays other moves such as
let's say Knight to c3 well the same
problem here black will continue with
the move rook to d8 and now a3 leads to
the same problem after the moon defy now
to illustrate my point I like to show
you one of my game where my opponent
continued here with the move Queen to be
even maybe he thought that I lost my
knight but actually it's not true here
black continue with the move Queen
captures if I check and you can easily
see that D pawn is running down the
board with some devastation now the only
good move over here is Bishop to e2 but
apart from Bishop to e2 if the open
place move such as Knight to e2 working
to diva then I have covered those lines
in the PGN so you can check it out in
the game my opponent continued with the
move Bishop to e2 indeed I continue with
the Moon D for attacking neide and now
he grabbed my knight so he thought that
ok white is losing one piece but in
return white gained two piece but in
fact the position is more deadly than
that here I continue with the move pawn
captures and after rook captures a6
black and play this dazzling move Bishop
to b4 so simple idea c2 and nabbing the
White Queen the only
reply over here is Castle which is
played by my opponent but then black
regain his piece with an interest and
now black has some deadly threats on the
back rank one simple example is let's
say if you open place Bishop to e3
then after c2 a white is completely
busted so that's not possible in the
game he tried Queen to a5 I played c2 so
now I am indeed threatening rook to d1
my opponent goes for some Queen trade
that is screened to f3
but then I was more than happy to do
this because after Queen captures pawn
captures rook to d1 rook captures a7 and
castle on the King side White has pretty
much lost position due to the wonderful
pawn on the sepal the second move I can
try over here is g3 which is a choice of
many positional players but here as I
have highlighted earlier black Polana of
campaign is very simple so we are going
to continue here with the moon g6 after
Bishop to g2 Bishop to g7 already White
has some problems on the e4 square now
if I try to defend this pawn with the mu
F 4 then the simplest is you continue
with the MU Epps's attacking one more
time and now there is no way white can
defend this pawn so white has to find
some other ways to create complications
and one way to do is to play Queen to e4
so now that Knight is hanging but here
black and simply reply with the
moonlight to b6 and now there are two
attacks on two sports which cannot be
defended so for example if b3 then after
pawn captures Bishop to e3 and now the
wonderful move D Phi will simply keep a
winning advantage to the black for
example if white continue here with the
move Bishop captures a 7 then after pawn
captures Bishop to b4 pawn captures f4
so there is a discover attack to the
rook only good way to the
Bendis bishop to c3 but after the move
Bishop captures Knight captures f3
Bishop to e3 and now the move III Black
has some deadly pawns on the 6th rank
and it gives more than a decisive
advantage well instead of Bishop to d7
in one game my opponent continued here
with the move Queen to e2 but after
Queen to f6 Knight to d2 and the movie
foe black has posted a wonderful point
chain in the center of the board and
kindly note black and always do
artificial castle with the MU King to f7
and rook to e8 now the third and the
most popular mode played over here is b3
well against it our plan of campaign
will remain the same this is something I
like very much about this line
can you guess blacks next move yes it's
very obvious g6 planning especially g7
and castle and for what white can do
well here the main move is f4 but apart
from f4 White has tried other moves such
as Bishop to e3 and g3 so let's look at
them first what happens if you open in
place Bishop to e3 well the simplest is
you block that diagonal with the moon d6
and the same time attacking the e-file
here f4 is not possible so the only way
to come out from this is capturing this
pawn but then comes Queen captures
Bishop captures Bishop to g7 attacking
the rook so white is forced to go into
this line after pawn captures Knight
Bishop captures Bishop Keane captures
Bishop captures rook pawn captures pawn
captures Bishop captures and now simply
castle on the Queen side where White has
a knight and a two points for the rook
but in such an endgame position they are
ineffective and it is only black who is
having advantage the second side line
move out can try over here is g3 so b3
and g3 combined together
but nevertheless we are going to
continue a plant that is after g3 Bishop
g7 Bishop to b2 and now castle on the
Kings side and after the move Bishop to
g2 we are going to target the feek ePHI
pawn with the move rook to e8 I have
played two games in this line where in
the first game my opponent defend the e5
pawn with the move f4 which is always
good sign for us because we can
immediately attack it with the mu Epps's
and funny enough in this case white
cannot even take that pawn my opponent
continued here with the move Queen to d2
so his idea is to attack the night but
after pawn captures pawn captures and
now the simple move pawn captures even
though White has a piece advantage his
position is completely lost let me show
you how here the force response is king
to d1 afterwards black continue with the
move f3 attacking the bishop bishop to
have fun Bishop captures rook captures
Bishop captures Queen captures and now
the star move Queen to e2 and black is
completely winning so to cut the long
story short but has the only good reply
over here is f4 now against f4 I'm
recommending that you should heat out in
the center immediately with the move d6
kindly note if Queen move somewhere for
example let's say Queen to f2 or Queen
to d2 then the simplest is you move this
night from b6 to d7 where it
participates to pressurize the e5 square
so that means White has to find some
other good alternatives now the 1st and
the bad alternative is Bishop to e3
because it simply lose a pawn after
Knight captures f4 so that cannot be
good
if white plays Bishop to g2 which is a
second bishop move then black can simply
continue here with the move Bishop to g7
and now in order to save the pawn white
has to attack the knight and the one
tricky way white can do is Quint we have
three so attacking Knight and Beyond c6
but here black has this dazzling reply
he can't just Fi and no matter however
white plays he has a lost position so
for example if white try to grab a piece
after pawn captures then the simplest is
pawn captures with a check and now not
only that dark square Bishop is gone but
rook in the corner also falls in the
next more the third move white can try
over here is e captures d6 well this is
the worst version of the last line which
we have seen because after Queen
captures Bishop captures and the move
Bishop to g7 we have the familiar
exchange forcefully happen that is pawn
captures Knight Bishop captures Bishop
King captures Bishop captures rook and
after pawn captures and pawn captures
this time around White has only one pawn
and a knight for the rook last but not
least White has this tricky move Queen
to f3 which has a very sneaky idea that
if you move the knight then the c6 pawn
drop as well as the rook in the corner
but here black has this sufficient good
reply that is Knight to be four so not
only defending the c6 but attacking on
c2 now if white play passively then
after D captures ePHI black obtain a
winning advantage so the force reply is
a three but then black and continue with
the moon night to see to check King to
d1 and now not capturing the rook in the
corner but to come back and defend the
c6 and the same time attack
the Queen I reached this position
against a one high rated opponent where
he continued with the move Queen to e4
but after D captures ePHI F kept us ePHI
and castle on the Queen side White has a
disgusting position at this point my
opponent find nothing better than night
to d2 but after Knight captures b3
attacking the knight Queen to g4 check
rope to d7 a6 attacking the rook F
captures c6 rope to a - defending the
knight but after Bishop - at six the
pressure has build up so much that
sooner or later black is going to be no
peace and in fact the King the fourth
and the final move I can try over here
is a knight to d2 well against this plan
of campaign is very consistent we are
going to continue with the moon g6 and
now if your opponent players move such
as b3 or g3 then we are obviously going
to continue with the move Bishop to g7
and castle on the Kings side with attack
on e5 so the only logical reply over
here is Knight to f3 idea is to play a
Bishop to g5 now apart from Knight to f3
there is a sneaky move over here which
can trap Black Knight which you need to
aware of it and the move is Queen to e4
now here if you try the same stuff which
is night to be fall then white can
indeed play the move a3 and this time
around defy doesn't work the simple
reason is here the Queen has a space to
run to the b1 square and now your knight
is simply trapped I once fall for this
trap and that's why I'm making sure that
you are not going to fall for it so
instead of night to be four at this
point black has a better reply and that
is F Phi
if Queen 2d for the night to be for
indeed will happen so the best reply
over here for the white is to capture
the spawn but then after night captures
Queen captures Bishop captures not only
black is ahead in the development but
black has some open files to walk on his
attack okay back to the main line that
is night we have three well before
Bishop g5 happens I'm recommending over
here that you should certainly Harris
White King why the MU queen check tally
note Bishop to b2 is not possible due to
the b2 pond fall so the other replies
needs to be considered the first one I
want to consider is Queen to d2 which is
in fact a blunder
because after Bishop captures c4 Black
has won an important pawn and the
tactical justification of this line is
if Queen captures then Bishop captures
comes with a check so why doesn't have
time to capture over bishop so obviously
Queen to d2 is not possible that leads
to the second reply that is night to d2
well after that I'm recommending that
you should continue with your normal
plan that is Bishop to g7 well the whole
point is after the move III black will
retrieve his Queen back after Queen to
e7 and now no longer white has this
Bishop g5 ideas so I'll just give you a
sample line let's say Knight to f3
trying same stuff but this time it's not
going to work because after Castle and
Bishop to g5 black as a simple reply f6
and this will completely refute this
line so for example after pawn captures
Queen captures Bishop captures Knight
captures castle on the King side Knight
to e4 attacking be true pressure up to
c1 and now rook a to even and it is
black who has all the pieces plays
aggressively
last but not least white can play the MU
King to Devon but if you have to move
the King just in the opening then I
seriously have doubt that white is
playing for the win here obviously
you're going to continue with the Moon
Knight to b6 and after the move b3
we can play the move Bishop to g7 and
black has a simple plan to castle on the
Kings side put the screen back on he 7
and then asking a question what this
funny King doing on the demon square ok
moral has to be completely dealt with
the c4 so now it's time to look at the
other line which is Knight 2 d2 which I
personally found not that attractive for
the white anyways our plan is simple yup
it's g6 light we have three same idea
and we have the same plan that is Queen
to b4 check again
white options are very limited for
example if c3 then Knight captures c3 if
Bishop to b2 then Queen captures b2 so
that leads to the same replies which we
have seen already the first reply I want
to consider is Queen to d2 well against
this I'm recommending you should
continue with the move rook to b8 and
now there are two replies tried over
here against me in the first game
my opponent played the move c4 but after
Queen captures Bishop captures night to
befall King to d1 and now the simplest
move C Phi will give more than
sufficient advantage to the black second
tries a three well against this I'm
recommending you should exchange the
Queen and after the move Knight to d2 we
can continue with the move Bishop to g7
and after the move c4 we can play the
move Knight back to e7 so right now
black is attacking ePHI the obvious way
to defend is to play F over but then
comes up 6 attacking the pawn one more
time
and after EF 6 Bishop f6 rope to be won
defy pawn captures and now the wonderful
move push up to a fire
so those bishops are really killing
white right now but is forced to move
his rook after rook to e1 and seek
access defy black obtained a pretty good
position now just to illustrate my point
if white continues here with the move
Bishop to e2 which is an issue looking
move then black can obviously capture
this pawn and after Bishop captures and
rook captures not only black has posted
the rook on the 7th and stopped fight to
castle on the Kings side but Black has a
wonderful central pawns and not to
mention black is also a pawn up apart
from Queen to d2
if opponent plays Knight to d2 a king d1
that's a knight to d2 then after Bishop
g7 and c4 we transposed with the line
which we have already covered kinda note
more such as e3 is good for black
because after Queen to e7 black is a
tempo ahead in this situation same goes
with the King D 1 because after King to
Devin bash up g7 and c-4 be transposed
to the line which I have already shown
that's it guys I hope with this brief
analysis you are now confident enough to
meet the squash game especially against
the move Knight captures c6 the plan I
have recommended throughout the game is
very consistent so in the most of the
cases you are going to go g6 Bishop g7
castle on the King side and there's a
typical idea to attack on the e5 and it
is not surprising that in many lines
black get a tremendous advantageous
position well thank you for watching
this video feel free to like subscribe
and comment on my video and I'll meet
you in my next episode Knight to c3
variation very soon bye and take care
so straight away let me enter to the
main line which occurs when white plays
the moves c3 and now here I recommend
that we should play the move Knight to
f6 instead of that I'm recommending a
line which will not only equalize black
only in the opening stage but it is the
black who is having all the fun the move
I am proposing is defy so counter
attacking in this